surely I don't expect to eat
anything healthy I hope my
judgment is not overly severe
[Music]
wealth because we have it too
but there is no cheese this thing
worries me just like average hamburg
there is no cheese  the
bright yellow but does not know anything like
eating an eye pringles france a
here this time they say that they have been
artificially flavored with that
same weight they work are reasons
and yet after sure no no I can pretend
but george is not a dirty word it seems
a little bit  food for you
[Music]
a very sweet
is a thing trimmed intense rain
not even to the dogs killed her in Italy they
are not spicy
the names are small I know nothing they are
composed of a 90 per cent dye
from a 10 per cent potato no classic
demolish this  it's called like a
wiz khalifa song made with
real fruit and again i doubt the
credibility of american ingredients
yuck you wear or man  already it looks like a
harmonic church the silly amount the
mouth deprived me of salivation for
10,000
good
i think guys it gets better
really i dont think i will ever go to the
united states and towards the bastards try
something else
really
[Music]